un altro bio la propria fiera che siamo
a secco è bello e tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo video sono fa vj oggi
siamo tornati su feltri è stato in
assoluto uno dei giochi più belli che
abbia mai fatto nella storia con i
ragazzi veramente nell'ultimo episodio
mette riempito di idee su cosa da fare
su face league e tanto prima di
cominciare a volevo fare era una cosa
troppo etica non crederete ai vostri
occhi però devo farvelo vedere
assolutamente mai viste le sedi atto che
ero un polipo cazzo levante ho bevuto
hanno aggiunto 8 del 2 stufe su facebook
c'è io non ho veramente parole ragazzi
già era figo adesso più primo comunque
cavolano vedere se riuscivo a fare cose
strafighe tra l'altro ma i baffi di ott
bisogna fare dei baffi veri per imitarli
come fai perché se rimarrò con un occhio
chiuso l'altro lo chiude ma non del
tutto mio nome essere 8 del bio bio
bello anche ragazzi voglio vedere se
riuscivo a trovare un po di gente su
ogni gol con con federica anche se nel
debito pro ci provo perfetto ragazzi ci
siamo vedove tedesco a fare qualcosa di
decente tipo viola la prima vittima
sacrificale giorno per chi a ragazzi
come se fossi un polipo ora deve esserci
casca la gente e bell'uomo la faccia non
esiste un polipo evitato reti ascoltami
tutti siano dei polipi nella vita c'è
bisogna capire che certe cose vanno
accettate quindi sono persone diversa la
si accetta bravo coach leggio bravis
come ti sembra da sex argine da una 10
vai zio
[Musica]
1 cosa uno zio
hai capito no no no tu hai per il kun
ascolta facciamo una cosa esso tumini ti
va bene ecco qualche chiudi quest'occhio
qua bene così così proprio da smog di
rinchiuderlo sono funziona l'altro grave
è che adesso la fai tanto il figo prova
ad alzare invece i baffi
e che cazzo di skippy appena visto che
non ci riusciva è uscito fantastico
bravo che cosa cazzo appena visto lo ha
mai visto un polipo così figo in vita tu
abbia veritate un film grazie grazie mi
è lo so non so me lo dicono tutti
guardai tra l'altro sono anche un
bravissimo polipo in grado di fare delle
tante espressioni facciali tipo posso
sorridere
e se il triste sono i tre visto salire
l'iter è riuscito a farti ridere così
bellissimo 23 metti il drago perfetto è
proprio questo caro amico lo vuole il
drug test o no
manco per il caso questo è il drogato
non della roba da sballo cazzo è
perfetto più grande desiderio in questo
momento tu tu che hai raccolto le sette
sfere del drago di sopra esprime non
desidera che punta a fuoco scusami zio
dai mal di gola colpisce tutti ma sei un
grande grazie a 09 io lo so che sono
grande sono un drago più grande della
con te amico mi immagino un drago così
possente che si mette a cantare di poker
le tagliatelle di quello che scriveva
ama davvero non dai espressioni facciali
anta qualcosa ma come hai mai visto un
drago che canta 0 al canto che batte mai
visto un drago che il canto emis killa
arrivo amore chiedo però ne prova un
altro che è dedicata a tutti i draghi
mareco che sognare perché sei te che fai
da te cuore a me
una più tornata che vi di justin viva
[Musica]
grazie grazie grazie per i complimenti
era tutto a posto mi stai è stato un
grande è piaciuto alla grande mela sono
verga ha viaggiato in capo al mondo in
cerca delle sfide più estremi e nei
luoghi più pericolosi poiché ti insegno
un po di tattiche di sopravvivenza amico
mio
come sopravvivere in cucina e una
settimana orditi labbro e cassetti senza
tante sexy un lupo tesi morde il labbro
ocre e di essere un animale più veloce
di me ti prendi per il culo e la ciao
come stai file raw ha visto che tu sei
una ragazza che quindi puoi descrivere
la sec saggini di questi animali che ne
dici di questo di che tu ha conquistato
con questo sguardo molto sexy
[Musica]
hardy paper parità lamentando del mio
sguardo per caso che allora vediamo di
fare uno sguardo molto più sexy che tipo
questo sbaglierei perché questa
grandissima volpe sexy è la prima volta
che esce dalla tana offender sorriso ed
io tanto serio fa un sorriso ma è bravo
così il sugo la vita ben fateh aspetto
aspetto frate non aspetta chiesto fai
col telefono guarda che non va bene
cioè è poi fa cazzo vuoi che chi è chi è
quel gran figo sulla sinistra volta
facciamo così tu mi dai le tue cuffiette
e io ti do i miei occhiali piacciono
rayban questi era marghera o bravo tra
le cose che faccio mai poi così la serie
c imitarmi sto per comandare due persone
e anche lì pronti grande lo zio avrai è
sopra la testa
questo fatto come assieme dio del corso
come e poi scappa ma che cazzo skippy
famiglia ascolta ascolta hai visto mai
un panino che somiglia fa vj c'è insomma
invece i due autori io sono le patatine
tiene faccia momento lonate via ebbe dai
prendiamo la coca cola mag menù è lepini
dove le mettiamo insieme
non si tratta così un panino è stata la
causa che riconosce per vivere per una
grazia che sei un mito del giurì guarda
anche per me è un piacere conoscerti
porta apparirà la porta su i ragazzi
direi che posso concludere qui anche
perché ci metta anni per evitare un
video di feltri figuriamoci se c'è di
mezzo puro mi colui che ragazzi è stato
fantastico ancora ci sto prendendo la
mano non ci sto giocando seriamente
quando inizierò a giocarsi seriamente
iniziare a far cose senza senso ma
quello lo vedremo più avanti
i ragazzi però ci propone che possono
chiudere qui servito è piaciuto ma senza
è stato un commento mi piace anche la
pace di facebook e con i video tratte
nella nelle tette
se avresti dischi da ieri ci vediamo il
prossimo video è la ragazzi